damit werden muss
wasser hat vorjahr
herzlich willkommen in monats fünf
minuten
heute morgen war es richtig cool ist und
zwar geht es wieder um eine
resteverwertung ich habe einfach mal ein
paar sachen zusammen gesammelt womit
zuhause rumliegen haben bis auf fleisch
ist hab ich frisch geholt und ein ganz
einfaches rezept mit ganz einfachen
zutaten weil die einfachsten dinge sind
immer die besten natürlich immer wieder
kochen auf geringem bildungsniveau das
heißt ich werde mich alleine kochen und
zwar ich werde meine assistentin bin ich
dabei haben darf ich mein assistent
hingelegt das ist unser knie ist auch
der beweis ist mit geringem
bildungsniveau kochen und backen kann
und deswegen habe ich dabei auch so und
deswegen ganz ganz einfach sachen und
zwar machen wir heute so eine
ich weiß ob es orientalisch ich weiß
nicht ob es bis in indische ist alles
mit dabei
nennen wir es einfach indem war chrysler
kann ich ja gleich sparen die ganz
einfach auch gleich vorne und ich haben
uns ja vorgenommen etwas gesünder zu
kochen haben uns vorgenommen und in der
ersten woche war schon wieder hinüber
deswegen machen einfach dinge die uns
gut schmecken und sparten einfach genau
wir achten trotzdem auf umwelt wir haben
genug ganz tolle sachen geholt
glückliches fleisch politischen hühnern
auch die paprika die ist im aus genießen
knobloch sagte er na ja genau und auf
jeden fall ganz ganz einfach sachen so
fangen wir an
500 gramm hackfleisch dann haben wir das
ding nicht genau
rindfleisch das waren dazu hat genau
dann haben mir kerbel kerbel hammer hier
das thema gesund aus der kerbel aber das
ist egal
da haben wir zwei chilischoten da man
hier zwei zielen schulden dann haben wir
hier vier esslöffel olivenöl 2
knoblauchzehen baugb nachher als bibel
dann haben wir zwei paprika dann haben
wir zwei esslöffel tomatenmark ein
bisschen gemüsebrühe und zwar
gemüsebrühe ganz einfach wir haben hier
einfach das selbstgemachte gemüse meiner
frau den link dazu findet sich hier
gerade hier unten und da haben einfach
dass das gemüse pulver genommen und
haben wasser eingefüllt und die
das gemüsebrühe richtig genau dann haben
wir hier kichererbsen kichererbsen aus
der dose
das ist es ist kein problem ich weiß ja
dass koreanisch ich habe es doch vorher
schon gesagt hab mich aufhalten wirst
dann haben wir hier kichererbsen aus der
dose da könnt ihr ruhig die aus der dose
nähmen das gar kein problem die ist
nicht schlecht die ist einfach auslosen
dann haben wir hier noch nachher für den
djp brauchen wir noch einen
zehnprozentigen basiert warum 10% ich
ganz einfach weil zehn prozent ist ein
cremiger ist das ist nicht so nicht so
schlag ich finde ich und schmeckt hat
richtig lecker ist ja so und aber
richtig lecker und dann haben wir noch
haben gesagt genau vorher ich gemerkt
das ist kein kerbel das ist koriander
minze für die genau und und nachher noch
ein bisschen mit mir jetzt ein zwei zu
tag nicht da hat zu hause ist nicht
schlimm wenn man 1 2
da fehlt man kann auch einfach noch
gucken was im kühlschrank hat und noch
dazu geben oder wenn ich jetzt noch
champignons hätte ich noch champignons
mit rein gegeben ich hätte noch ziele
mit rein gegeben ich gucke auch grad
frühlingshaft auch ein paar alles rein
geben es gar kein problem nach also nach
geschmack genau dann fangen wir angelegt
und günstig ist übrigens auch damals
gerade die seite so wie jetzt packen wir
an unser folgendes wir machen unser
hackfleisch das hat verschiedene gründe
wenn man hat gleich selber macht heißt
man was drin ist denn in allem was
zusammen gepasst oder gemixt oder oder
geschreddert oder gehackt wurde
meist macht kann man immer was rein
machen jetzt wissen was drin ist und
zwar prüfte genommen was ich vielleicht
nicht gemacht haben es ist ja vorher
schon gut aufgefallen ich habe ein
bisschen weniger fett genommen weil man
beim hackfleisch komme ich ein bisschen
mehr festnehmen
es gibt noch einen coolen geschmack aber
ich habe gedacht bei der queen ii heute
heißt und er einen hohen
cholesterinspiegel hat und ansonsten
auch gesundheitliche probleme habe ich
gedacht nämlich die gesundheit stand
gleich das problem wenn ich was anderes
deswegen habe ich ja höchst genommen
denn auch obst fleisch dann wird man am
anfang mit knoblauch und zwiebeln zu
packen
richtig genau ich würde nur zwei gingen
eben nur zwei stück wellen nach dem
einlenken
da sieht man auch noch was rein so jeder
zwischenzeit
mache ich schon mal das hackfleisch und
zwar nehme ich hier das gemüsemesser und
schneit es fleisch in mehrere teile
und zwar das fleisch mache ich mit dem
mgv transformer so irgendwie habe ich
daraufhin messer wir haben auch das
falsche messer genommen jetzt weil es
schon gemüsemesser und das tue ich jetzt
in streifen schneiden
während bin jetzt hier dass die zwiebeln
schneidet mache ich den hut und zwar
einfach hier rein und dann drehen
so jetzt siehts denn rein
[Musik]
hast du gesehen innerhalb von einer
minute halbes kilo gleich gemacht ohne
strom
wahnsinn oder jetzt können wir auch mal
machen heißt das ging du bist das beste
dankeschön für mich auch ganz toll gegen
das wetter passt du bringst du dir mir
stadt eingefallen
ihr könnt euch niemals veganer wert
meist mit deinen wurstfinger wer das
nicht möglich das war richtig das
herrlich was wir erst mal hat das team
von potash one board heißt auf deutsch
heißt es eintopf wussten natürlich nicht
wenn du kein englisch kann zuschlagen
danke schön bin so froh dass mich ja
wahnsinn auf jeden fall hauptschüler
achte klasse leistungskurs englisch war
nicht super klasse jetzt immer folgendes
jetzt tut mir ein bisschen olivenöl
nehmen zwar machen die pampa niemals
alleine erhitzen oder halt nicht alleine
meine ich den topf und pfanne niemals
leer erhitzt jetzt gehen wir hier gleich
auf mittlere stufe langsam anfangen zu
herzen
die pannen bogen und dann angefangen
bogen gibt nicht mehr so wie die hier
über das so sieht hat verfolgen zu
stellen die verformt sich dann leichter
sagen dass du zu heiß gebadet wollen auf
jeden fall die parlamentswahl und wir
tun jetzt die zwiebeln oder knoblauch an
diensten richtig ins schwitzen
anschwitzen endlich ja anschließend
nicht mehr schwitzen was macht im leben
wenn man nichts macht man schlagen muss
man genau so genau
das ist ein trick von gummi und zwar
einfach große ziel rein wenn man
luftblasen kommt dann merken dass die
fans heiß genug ist richtig so überhaupt
ist schneller
jetzt kümmere paprika auch noch bin dann
immer neues jetzt gemüse neues bett und
zwar machen wir uns einfach aber neues
brett bin ich habe nicht mal heißt auch
schon ein neues bett und zwar
schön nun die paprika in streifen
schneiden und zusammen mit den zwiebeln
und den knoblauch an dienste jetzt sehen
wir auch schon dass es die richtige
temperatur
es gibt diese bläschen muss reiner
wahnsinn
[Musik]
so jetzt richtig schön anschwitzen
genau
er hat genau in der zwischenzeit tue
einfach tomatenmark rhein ahr jawohl
temperatur ein bisschen weiter runter
jetzt hast du diesen richtig coolen
geruch von tomatenmark paprika zwiebeln
knoblauch jetzt nehmen wir hier den
koriander vom juni sorry koran damit
rein und jetzt wirklich wenn die paprika
noch richtig schön bist es sind jetzt zu
hackfleisch rein
dabei soll ich mit der paprika so
richtig leben dass bei uns im
schwäbischen kenntnis und jetzt zum
erfolgen dass erst ein bisschen
knoblauch knoblauch eines hackfleisch
rein aber immer nur ein bisschen wenn
jetzt alles auf einmal machen damit zu
wässrig und wirklich kurz ein bisschen
rein kurz bisschen anbraten genau die tv
show mit rein klasse bis heute ist so
richtig mit ja wirklich der wahnsinn
wo jetzt gehöre den rest vom hat gleich
noch reinmachen unschön anbraten das
hackfleisch das ist auch richtig krümel
liegt wird und jetzt zum einen ein
bisschen rum berühren und gucken das
ganze wasser weg ist nach belieben
einfach ein bisschen salz ein bisschen
pfeffer
wenn jetzt noch und wenn jetzt noch bock
habt auf chili oder was auch immer ein
haus einfach rein
auch das war's ja lust hab ich lieber
über alles soll in der zwischenzeit man
auf folgendes dann will man hier den
zehnprozentigen joghurt sagt brauche ich
mal nicht ich bin ja jetzt machen auch
den weg zusammen bin ich mal
reingefallen ist schon ein bisschen
knoblauch rein reiben
genau
und ein bisschen winzerei jetzt nur noch
ein bisschen salz knie oder kapseln und
jetzt richtig schön richtig schön
vermischen kommen ja noch die zweite
reihe nun auch kann nie genug sein auch
männer 11 und den und wie gesagt dass
ich das ganze wasser und vom fleisch und
von gemüse jetzt gleich weg und jetzt
prägt es richtig genial hand also
richtig scharf heißt es richtig machen
ja erst einmal kleine löcher könig und
zwar nehmen wir den hier egal so des
todes richtig cool zusammen bringt es
meinem kleinen lächeln kann es mal
probieren welt wenn nichts passiert dann
probiere ich auch das ist ja ich habe
alles fein gemacht habe habe ich keinen
gemacht kein problem
du willst du hast du brauchst eigentlich
nicht richtig genial nicht in der firma
kannst du vielleicht ein höherer
verbrauch so auf jeden fall jetzt ist es
angebraten und jetzt kommen ist einfach
ein bisschen ablöschen und zwar machen
die gemüsebrühe von der citi habe ich ja
immer wieder schon verlinkt und jetzt
mal die gemüsebrühe rein sonst noch ein
bisschen ablöschen und ganz zum schluss
die kichererbsen baum auch ganz zum
schluss fallen sind ja schon vor gekocht
worden
die idee die tiger erbsen und deswegen
müssen sie ja nicht mehr aus und legt so
haben wir am rhein
genau und jetzt ein paar noch mal
umrühren
[Musik]
wir kochen ist einfach man macht das auf
was man bock hat und jetzt habe ich kann
auch gesehen wir haben ja noch ein paar
frühlingszwiebel der könig kann ist es
ganz kurz schneiden ist schon gewaschen
wenig wollen ja wir sind schon noch mal
eine eingereicht eine reihe das ist ja
noch paar abfällige was würde daraus
macht jetzt aber noch überlegt einfach
nochmal die politischen reihen zu
schmeißen und das macht spaß
chinesisch kochen oder einfach das
reinste bock hat was ist jetzt noch lust
man könne jetzt alle drei machen möchte
ist surfen surfer surfen torf ist eine
viel zu sagen
[Musik]
jetzt haben ein paar fröhliche
reingemacht das passt alles richtig kalt
wird es richtig ist auch richtig cool
willst du mal zwischenzeitlich probieren
aber schmeckt ganz großen respekt an
nicht das hatte ich echt gut gemacht ich
hab schon so klasse nehmen so
anprobieren den vulkan
[Gelächter]
aber wir kriegen wir sagen das ist so ja
genau ist merkt derjenige alles böse
kommt das machen was du für deinen
gedanken heißt das ist darüber dass
diese hinterhältigen gedanken hat aber
ich würde davon abhalten
wir holen einfach kurz empathie gleichen
buddy holen genau darum in baden-baden
probieren
das ist unschön noch anrichten wie nie
so gemacht dass meine frau immer das
machen wir tun es jetzt so machen und
dann thomas ein becken und zwar wenn man
löffel
und jetzt noch ein bisschen außen rum
hab ich's mal im fernsehen gesehen
es ist nicht toll aus ist richtig cool
aus sagte badi probieren
allerdings passiert dann essen wir ja
auch gedacht alles läuft braucht ja und
zwar sich eine ganz einfache parkhäuser
in japan ein bisschen orientalischen und
jetzt probier mal läuft sie sich richtig
aus und legen hingegen das ist wahnsinn
hast du was du beschlüsse ja ich kann
nicht nicht dauernd arbeiten müssen
gegensatz zu dir schmeckt doch wird ich
mag das sowieso hackfleisch mit gemüse
ich hab mich nur gefragt schmecken der
erklärt uns mal hieß ihm schmecken
lassen
sternekoch ja ein sterne gucken erst der
linken was besseres als wir 2 hast du ja
wir sind freunde so nach so alle auf den
kleinen regen ok aber ich richtig cool
also beschloss ich wünschte es würde
mich freuen wenn ich etwas zu essen
bekommen würde ist ja ihr habt hier
sehen wir alle zusammen geschmissen
eigentlich ging auch relativ schnell
wenn er ein bisschen schneller gewesen
wäre ist ja leider nicht
du kannst es mit dem bunny alles gute
klasse gemacht genießt ganz cool das
rezept im juni zusammen ich hoffe euch
hat es gefallen war ein bisschen
durcheinander ein bisschen anders als
bei der rallye aber das ist auch nicht
unsere priorität ist auch nicht backen
und kochen der abgehörten ja wir wollen
und werden
und richtig toll also mit recht stolz
auf uns zwei das habe ihr tolles video
kochen auch geringem bildungsniveau mit
gummi und redet mit uns hätte die
anderen sollen anderen hätten weil das
hätten heißt es ist so wie ja genau
heckens auch an meine freunde da ja noch
mein moment moment freunde
wir kennen uns halt genau genau wir
arbeiten unter dem gleichen dach mit
bekannten bekannt genau auf jeden fall
hätte die anderen macht's gut macht's
besser
[Musik]